good morning oh brother good afternoon
welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee
i'm councillor alastair mccraw and i'm
chairing the meeting today
may i first remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
uh that you do not interrupt other
speakers and that if you attend
the meeting to speak and you
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave
please ensure that mobile phones are
either on silent or switched off
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed
by the council to have consented to
being filmed and by entering this
meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council
and the possible use of those images and
sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
and the council members of the public
and the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when
the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
so to introductions i'll now ask the
governance officer to carry out the
introductions
thank you chair um so today the cabinet
members present
are uh councillor julie flatman a
mid-suffolk cabinet member for
communities um
i am not sure i saw council davis
actually i'm sorry i'm just checking i
don't think council david i looked in
the uh
i looked in the attendance i couldn't
see him no that's fine so
okay and other counselors in attendance
are also counselor morley councillor
heirs
councillor mabry and counselor general
spawn and the officers present today
are vicki mosley corporate manager for
communities
and i think jan robinson deputy monitor
officer and corporate manager for
governance and civic office
thank you thank you very much henrietta
um can i move to the agenda please now
item one on today's agenda is apologies
for absence and substitutions
thank you chair we have no apologies um
however i will do a roll call of members
now
please can members are answer or respond
when i call your name please counselor
dawson here
council gold good afternoon
council grandin here
council mccraw present council mclaren
president councillor adrian osborne
good afternoon present council carter
good afternoon council casting present
council epcon young present
council muller present cancer scarf
present and councilwell present
thank you chair all members are present
thank you item two is to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members are
there any to declare
councillor eppinyon oh sorry no it's
councillor muller i apologize
yes thank you chair um i should declare
that i am a member of the mid suffolk
citizens device trustee board thank you
that would be entirely non-pecuniary and
uh so that doesn't exclude you from any
part of the discussion or voting
any others
in that case we'll go to item three
which is jos 2011
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the joint overview and
scrutiny committee
held on the 23rd of november 2020
these minutes were deferred from the
last committee meeting
if members can turn to those pages are
there any
points regarding the accuracy of those
minutes
then can i ask for a proposal please
happy to propose chair thank you very
much
councillor muller proposing and a
seconder please
yeah happy to second councillor welcome
thank you councillor welcome
um if that's everything we shall now
conduct an electronic vote and i'll ask
the government's officer to carry that
out
members are directed to the voting
screen
thank you chair member can you please
cast your uh
vote uh on the app now on the
item jos 2011
if you click on the uh plus button at
the top of
your agenda and then again at the plus
actually the vote should be started
i can see my colleague hasn't started
yet so let's do that
that's now showing in blue as you've
been progress now
cancer grandin are you okay for voting
on the modern.gov app
i've done it has it not been received
not yet i can take your vote i have that
well i did vote for that's fine we'll
put your form
i have actually submitted it but i think
it must be my
that's
something weird going on yes i have yes
that's fine chair with
my technical issues come on that's fine
chair with the council brandon's vote um
the vote is
uh 12 votes four thank you very much so
that's uh
passed we shall now move to the minutes
of the meeting
uh there have been confirmed and will be
signed at the next practicable
opportunity item four is confirmation of
the minutes of the joint overview and
scrutiny committee
held on the 14th of december 2020.
these minutes will be deferred to the
next overview and scrutiny committee
meeting
in march item 5 bos
25 is to confirm the baba minutes
of the meeting held on the 18th of
january so please note
that only baber members can vote on this
item
so baby remembers are there any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
in that case can i have a proposal
please
i'll propose it dawson cancer dawson
councillor dawson thank you very much
and a second to please
sorry council mclaren second in thank
you very much councillor mclaren
i'll now ask the governance officer to
conduct the electronic vote
once again only the baby members are to
vote upon this item
uh that's fine members if you can please
cast your vote on the app
the vote should be in progress
if you scroll down to item bos 25
and click on the cross you should be
able to um
or the plus sign you should be able to
vote now i can see a lot of you are
doing it anyway so i'll be quiet
[Music]
i note that in fact there are two
confirmed buttons you have to press
one after the other so that may be the
reason for some earlier confusion
and let's see
i'm still missing one vote
do we know which member that would be
well
i
sorry henry i think you've received all
of the votes from the baby members
yes i think so too uh so that is
unanimous that's uh six votes for
chan thank you very much and that those
minutes will be confirmed
it's five votes four and
we're not present councillor gould i
quite understand um the uh
minutes of that meeting would be have
now been confirmed and will be signed at
the next practicable opportunity
item six on the agenda is mos 25
to confirm the mid-suffolk minutes of
the meeting held on the 14th of january
2021
uh please note that only mid-suffolk
members can vote on this item
i'll ask them if there are any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
in that case can i have a proposal
please
happy to propose chair councillor muller
thank you very much councillor mueller
and a seconder
happy to second chair councillor
thank you very much paul and that case
i'll ask henrietta to carry out the
electronic vote
mid-suffolk members only here
so uh yes members please if you can cast
your vote on the app now please it the
vote should be in progress for item
mos 25.
i'll keep an eye on
so chair we have six vote four
which is unanimous okay once again
those minutes of the meeting held on the
14th of january 2021 will be have been
confirmed
and will be signed at the next
practicable opportunity
item seven on the agenda ah we seem to
have lost uh councillor osborne who
appears to want to come back in again so
we'll just allow that to happen
well i think we now have councillor
osborne
yeah thank you sorry no that's okay no
problem at all
item seven on the agenda is to uh
receive notifications of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
non-received chair thank you item eight
is
questions from the public uh
non-received chair thank you very much
and item nine
questions by councillors non-received
chair
thank you very much so we'll now move to
um
item seven on the agenda or is it item
10 i must admit i'm having a little
difficulty with numbering here
but uh it is item 10 and this is the uh
annual review of local citizens advice
lca
for short now i don't know if this will
be possible but i'd like to invite
vicki mosley the corporate manager for
communities
to introduce report jos 20 stroke
12. um i noticed that we have one of the
cabinet members present in councillor
flatman
and if councillor flatman wishes to add
anything more than happy to hear that
along the present side alongside the
presentation
so over to vicki hi thank you chair
um this is just a very very short report
primarily acknowledging the
cabinet's decisions back in january 2020
to award
both stone market and suddenly districts
cas with three year funding agreements
so they are now in place and my grants
officers are currently working through
so the details with
those cas um and also
uh to introduce basically the
presentation that you'll be receiving
later on this session from the cas
direct
at the time of writing this report
however we did receive confirmation from
stepford and disc that they wouldn't be
applying for
a revenue grant from us for 2122 so
i've also added that into the report so
like i said it's a very short report um
primarily introducing the the
presentation that you're about to
receive from and the ca
so unless there are any questions for me
then it's probably best to just review
the
or listen to the presentation that's
coming up yes i think that's that's
probably appropriate um
um at this point can i ask members some
have any questions of vicki
uh councilman muller thank you chair uh
just a quick question though vicki
um because um this thetford and uh the
district ca no longer
uh require that funding um do residents
who make use of this service
in those areas do they actually live in
mid-suffolk and if so
could that funding be transferred to the
mid-suffolk citizens advice thank you
um yeah and i think that's definitely a
conversation that might come up in the
in the presentation
so certainly what what seems to have
happened with um stepford and dis is
that
a lot of their uh customers were due to
the
from the footfall from the shopping
that's existed over the last year but we
know that through cover
most of the shops have um been forced to
close therefore the regular footfall has
disappeared
as well therefore the demand in the
service hasn't been what it has
what could have been or would have been
um
but yeah there's definitely a
conversation i think to have with stone
market ca with regards to how we move
forward
uh in terms of where those customers
would typically come from and we'll be
in touch anyway with effort and disk to
maintain ongoing dialogue with them to
see how if anything changes with their
situation as the next year progresses
um and then we'll have another
conversation with them but we'll need to
absolutely capture
where those customers come from and i
think
that conversation could happen um as
part of the presentation later
thank you very much vicky thank you
thank you i i note uh we have
questions from councillor scarf and then
councillor epinyong
thank you chair yes um on page 44
table 1 shows a 53
500 pound contribution uh by baby
district council to
submit district ca however on page 46 in
section 8 it shows
five thousand five hundred i'm sure
that's a typo could we just have
clarification on that
yes that's been confirmed already
councillor scoff
picked up in the papers in preparation
okay we were primed for this
this small point in fact the leader of
one of the councils was only too keen to
point this out to me
so i think we'll let that pass but yes
that's good these
things happen uh councillor and then
councillor
thank you chairman um and actually uh
counselor
scarf just asked one of the questions i
was going to pose but actually
a little bit of clarity is it 53 or is
it 35
53 it's the larger figure okay super
uh so my second question is with regards
to section five
and six of the report and and it does
seem to me
that we seem given that the the award is
for a three year period
we appear to be placing a a rather
a severe admin burden on the ca
in terms of reporting and and
reapplying for funding and repeating
information that is unlikely to have to
change
in the course of the period for example
presenting
key policies over and over seems to me
to be
somewhat superfluous and i just wondered
why
we have such a need for such a heavy
admin burden on the ca
are you referring to paris 5.3 here
well 5.2 5.3
and 6.1 okay that's fine i mean the
reasons for those that vicky could
answer those that would be great i mean
there are there are reasonable checks
and balances
yeah i mean we do have to maintain
reasonable checks and balances and we
are
um often scrutinized and asked to
clarify what they are from time to time
so we do try to adhere to what our own
internal processes
are which have been agreed um as much as
we possibly can i think
when my grants officers will be working
alongside
the cas and we will use an element of
common sense so where they have a policy
that they've already provided and that
lasts for a period of time
then we will already have that on file
so we will just through conversation
with them
acknowledge that we've already received
those so i think that administrative
burden is reduced just by having those
ongoing
um conversations with them thank you
it's just a sort of mental reminder to
keep in touch i think as much as
anything else
and i mean uh that's fascinating that's
useful for anybody uh counselor
yes i i appreciate uh vicky's response
which does
make sense but i don't understand i
still don't understand the need for
for them to reapply annually for
something that we've agreed
for a three year period it's
it feels complicated but basically the
annual application is for
um three years in advance so when they
apply so when the cas apply
um next year or this year for grant it
will be for the
for the next three years following so
they do have their annual three year
they grant already secured but each year
it's almost topping those up because
what we will just
find is that as we have ongoing dialogue
and we'll have quarterly six monthly
meetings
some of the um activities some of the
work some of the demands on their
services will change
one year to the next and so we need to
be able to make sure that our
monitoring arrangements reflect the
changes in demand in the services in the
service
and it also gives the opportunity for us
to have conversation with
cas around the amounts that they have
that they don't necessarily
always remain static and as a
conversation obviously we are
governed to some degree by how much we
have in the overall budget but that also
provides some flexibility around that
albeit
quite marginal so i think it's a it's
mostly around
not being too strict with with what's
been agreed one year to the next
but also about those monitoring
arrangements and making sure that
we can flex the work that they they need
to be doing and that we can
we can cover that off in the monitoring
arrangement so that we know that what
they say they're they're delivering that
they actually are and we can monitor
that with them
and change as we need to uh does that
help you counselled opinion
if i if i could just add in that this is
not entirely
i think there's a statutory requirement
in fact um
in making in applying for grants that
requires an annual
process but it should be borne in mind
that we are actually
uh we're actually doing a three-year
rolling agreement
so that the council and the uh lcas
have some security of looking forward
for each three years at a time
so that when we do the annual
application it's not just for that year
it's for the two subsequent years uh as
well so
this keeps the the the process uh i
think they've got some security
i see uh tom barker who may have some uh
input on this
with is has his hand raised
um yes through you chair and and you
have actually covered
um in large part the point i was going
to make councilman mccrory but
if we didn't require an annual grant
process then what they would be getting
would be a three-year grant
not a three-year rolling grant and if
they just applied once every three years
then by the time you get to the third
year they would be facing exactly the
same scenario that councillors were keen
that they avoided which is that sense of
a cliff edge at the end of the grant
process
so as vicky explained and as councilman
crore
um kind of amplified we need to go
through the annual process
in order to continue to give them three
years looking forward
because otherwise it would just be a
three-year grant rather than a rolling
arrangement
yeah the the joint committee were keen
that the security for the
funding for the three-year period was
essential for them uh i have councillor
williams hand raised but i also know
councillor davis is in the meeting
and has his hand raised uh councillor
welland would you rather hear from
councillor davis first or would you like
to ask your question
i'm happy to hear from councillor davis
if he'd like to speak
and i'll come back to you councillor
well i'm councillor davis as
as one of the uh cabinet members for the
uh portfolio i wonder if you had
anything you wish to say
yeah thank you very much um in fairness
vicky and tom
have covered it um very well
but from a cabinet perspective and just
to assure council epping young that
this was something we really um
discussed in depth
and and as tom said in that piece there
which is the point i was going to make
it was very important that this
three-year rolling process
did have an annual monitoring very much
a light touch
um you know because the communities team
will go through with the cabs um
but i just wanted to be assured that
this was looked at at cabinet
before we made a approval for the
three-year
rolling budget for them and that's
pretty much everything else has been
covered now thank you
thank you very much councillor davis uh
back to you councillor wellam
thank you chair um i've been looking at
the risk
the risk assessments here and the
um there are three elements um and
of those two are very high risk
and i just wanted to make sure that
uh if if there are our funders
withdrawing their funding
or if covid continues that
there is still the ability uh for
mid-south
and i guess for baba too to increase
funding
it's been possible during the kobe
period through coveted funding
i just wanted to make sure that there
would be the flexibility
should funders reduce or withdraw their
funding or there be other problems
associated with
covert like the end of the furlough
scheme
okay uh vicky can you uh
address that at all yeah i mean i would
like to think that those the regular
meetings that we have with the cas well
you know alex on a quarterly basis we
always be keeping ourselves into the
ground working with them so
should that be the case and we will look
to do everything that we possibly can to
support the the cas
um again just having had a meeting with
one of the cas just last week we are you
know
aware that other funding has been
reduced um
to support them and we'd look to see
what we could perhaps do
to um to kind of fill those gaps but
there is
um a slight underspending in revenue
funds but not significant so we would
have to look across the whole piste as
to what the organization's
the council's priorities are in terms of
spend so could because
we can only spend what we have within
the actual budget
it's going to be a very changeable
position
for the foreseeable future um
right i think if members of the
committee have completed their questions
to
to the corporate manager i'd like to ask
if any other members present have any
questions
but this would be specifically for the
corporate manager
and the short presentation that was
given
are there any such members
okay in the absence of any hands i'll
remind you we'll be
debating the issues after both
presentations and questions
to the local citizens advice so we'll
now move on to that presentation from
the local citizens advice
can i introduce the chief officers
attending and the ones who'll be
providing the presentation
and they are respectively nikki wilshere
the chief officer at citizens of vice
ipswich
simon clifton of citizens advice
mid-suffolk
and colleen sweeney of sudbury and
district citizens advice
um thank you very much for attending all
three of you uh we look forward to
hearing your presentation
um henrietta will you be sharing the
screen for the presentation please
i am just working on getting it up let
me just
move things over so people can see
can members see that
yes that's come up now yeah okay okay
good afternoon everyone i'm colleen
sweeney i'm the chief officer of sudbury
citizens advice
um thank you for inviting us back to
speak to you all
about how we've been managing to
continue delivering our services
and the impact of the pandemic over the
past year
we do appreciate your interest in us
it certainly has been a strange year for
all of us and we do have some
interesting updates as a result
we've put together a fairly brief
presentation to cover the areas we were
asked to
and also to allow questions at the end
next slide please have a look
okay so by way of reminder for those of
you who were present at our last joint
scrutiny presentation
and to inform those of you who were not
i would like to speak briefly about who
we are and what we do
as you will know excuse me we can all
face problems that seem complicated and
intimidating
citizens advice we believe no one should
have to face these problems
without good quality independent advice
we give people the knowledge and
confidence to find their way
forward whoever they are and whatever
their problem
so when we say whoever you are we do not
place any limits
on the number of visits the client makes
we do not restrict to any particular
beneficiary group
anyone can come to see us for advice and
we do not judge people who come to see
us for advice
and when we say whatever your problem
we give advice on an extensive range of
areas
and we work with partners whenever
people need more specific
support or more specialist input that we
do not have
and by what we mean when we say to find
a way forward
we do not make decisions for clients we
present
options and empower them to act or
assist further
when the client is considered to have
more need
for in-depth support we match the
support we give to clients needs
so we do have clients who just need us
to point them in the right direction
and we do have other clients who need
more support
it's the case of assessing how confident
each person is
and the right approach for them next
slide please
okay so just short of a year ago
we were all beginning to realize that we
may be moving towards an unprecedented
situation
where we would need to make changes to
the delivery of our services
whilst ensuring that we remained
available to our clients
at a time that they would need us more
than ever
fortunately we were all able to act
quickly and keep the wheels turning
there were different approaches and
decisions made at each lca
based on variants which included our
buildings and space to work in
can i can i pause you there colleen we
appear to unlock
and uh you may you may find yourself
backtracking a sentence or so but i
apologize for that no worries
no worries i can say look at you simon
instead because you're the only person
on my screen at the moment
one moment chair i don't know quite what
happened there let me just find it
we had the pizza wheel of death for a
moment yes
there we are sorry is that okay for
everybody
okay okay yeah um so i was just saying
that we had to act quickly unfortunately
we were all able to
in um transforming services and there
were different approaches and decisions
made at each lca
based on variants which included our
buildings and space to work in
ability to meet demand quickly and
efficiently over the phone and by email
and of course the level of anxiety about
coming into our offices
that our teams fed back when individual
risk assessments were carried out
so in sudbury we were quick to move over
to phone and email advice in remote
working
using the equipment and technology that
we had
and have suspended seeing clients face
to face
whilst we've had some people working in
the office to keep things moving
volunteer advisors have instead been
working from home
and have since bennett benefited from
our new
additional equipment and technology that
we had secured funding for
with our additional support to ensure
their wellbeing and technical upskilling
this is all working well we have also
put into place provision for a limited
number of appointments to be offered
at our offices via a screen link once
restrictions are relaxed
and as an interim measure before we can
resume our
normal face-to-face advice services
ipswich lca took steps to allow those at
minimum risk to consider working in
their offices
and also made adaptations to allow
clients to enter the building
whilst government restrictions allowed
these changes
included setting up working from home
for staff and volunteers upgrading
telephony systems by purchasing soft
phones
and upgrading their technology and i t
equipment including the purchase of
laptops
increasing paid resources to allow them
to respond to increased telephone and
email demands
employing a security guard for the
building's entrance to ensure
social distancing purchasing and setup
of perspective
screens and sanitizer stations two meter
distancing measures were put into place
and furniture was reallocated to
accommodate them
protocols were written and video rooms
were set up for clients to have virtual
appointments in safe interview spaces
miss suffolk citizens advice identified
staff and volunteers who needed to
isolate
either due to age or medical conditions
addition additional i.t software and
mobile
phones were purchased for those who
required to work from home
from the first lockdown to the present
time the advice center at stone market
has remained open for staff and
volunteers
operating in covert secure environments
operational service was maintained
despite the loss of 50
of their volunteer advisors and 20
of their staff who were required to
shield
the remaining workforce were split into
two groups
working alternate shifts to ensure that
at least 50 percent of their resources
would be available in the event of local
a outbreak a five phase plan
from initial response through to a
return to normal service has been
adopted
in mid-suffolk and that is phase one
email and phone two
adding virtual advice from the office to
clients at home or in an external
setting
three add in virtual advice advice to a
client in the office
four add in face-to-face advice in the
office by appointment
and finally five add drop-in
appointments back when business is
normal next slide clears henrietta
so with regards to changes in demand
this graph shows the age groups of our
clients and comparisons that can be made
in 2018 19 and 20.
we've always helped people from every
age group and that continues to be the
case
but during the pandemic we have seen an
increa
increase in demand from younger age
groups
particularly people in their 20s and 30s
these tend to be clients who are
economically active
and have the digital skills to use other
access options than face to face
in fact this is often their preference
this new client group will continue to
seek our help now that they've found us
and will need our ongoing support
through the coming years to cope with
the covered fallout
for this reason our business plans
include actions for retaining
and developing the higher level of
digital service options that we now
offer
me however we are seeing fewer
of our over 60s client group who would
normally make up our majority client
group
we understand that many of this group
are unable to access our services by
phone
or email and rely heavily on the
face-to-face service delivery that we're
currently unable to offer
we know that this client group will be
coming back to us
with very complex and overdue problems
once normal services resume
[Music]
in short what we do know is that demand
for our services
will not simply change back to managing
the previous
ever increasing client group who
desperately need face-to-face advice
but will now also include those who are
able to
and prefer to access our services
remotely
next slide please
okay so this graph shows that there was
a dip
in client contacts during april may 2020
at the time when the government support
was generous
although the issues we saw at that time
were especially urgent
as people's lives were being turned
upside down
despite having closed our face-to-face
services
we are now seeing more clients than we
have at this time in previous years
this has been manageable even in crisis
due to the exceptional work of our
volunteers and staff
for which we are extremely grateful
all teams across our lcas have pulled
together
adapted to changes and coped with their
roles
whilst dealing with the personal impacts
of getting through these difficult times
admirably just to know on this graph
we often see clients more than once in a
year
this graph counts the client in the
first month that we see them
so although it looks like client numbers
reduced over a year
actually this is due to the way that the
replete clients
are counted and next slide please
[Applause]
since december december 2019
the number of people claiming universal
credit while you see
in baby has gone up by 119
and in mid suffolk by 122 percent
something that citizens advice is very
concerned about
is that at the start of the pandemic the
government
increased the rate of universal credit
by 20 pound a week
currently the plan is for that to stop
at the end of march
nationally the charity is lobbying for
the uplift to be made permanent
people have budgeted for that 20 pounds
a week
and it can easily represent the money
they have for a weekly shop
we would be very concerned about what
would happen in april if the rate
of uc is reduced we have a high number
of people on uc in the districts now
and if they suddenly find their uc has
gone down by around 100 pounds a month
we believe that they we would see more
families in crisis across our districts
okay i'll um pass on to simon now for
the next slide please
we appear to be getting some echo simon
i don't know
if that's a problem at your end or
something in the system
i'll try again chair thank you
so the slide that we're seeing here is a
slide trying to
demonstrate our change in demand across
the main areas in which we work
comparing 2083 2018 through to 2020
the last column shows the percentage
increase will decrease which i'll go
into
in more detail for the main issues that
we've got on this slot this
chart in the following slides next slide
please
[Applause]
so this slide has highlighted benefits
and universal credit
as shown in an earlier slide and
demonstrated by colleen a number of
clients help
universal credit has increased
dramatically over the past year
the reasons for this are well known and
linked to the economic and social impact
of the kobe pandemic on individuals and
families across our districts
the changing welfare benefit landscape
is clear with universal credit totaling
six percent of all issues in 2018
but now having risen to 20 risen 16
in 2020 a threefold increase
we were expecting to see an increase in
growth in our universal credit issues
as uc started to replace legacy benefits
such as job seekers allowance and tax
credits
but the pandemic has accelerated this
over the same period client issues or
other welfare benefit for other welfare
benefits and tax credits has decreased
although the decrease in other welfare
benefits issues is less than the
increase we have seen in uc
although there is no exact number for
the people on the job retention scheme
across our districts
when it ends we should prepare for large
job losses where companies are unable to
keep the money
keep them employed this will lead to
further increases in those having to
claim
universal credit a recent article in the
east anglian daily times identified
our districts but in particular parts of
mid-suffolk had seen some of the largest
increases in universal credit claims
across england in areas that had
been considered by many to be within
affluent communities
this just reinforces that the pandemic
has widely impacted all levels of income
and there are many now claiming welfare
benefits for the first time
in their working life next slide please
this slide demonstrates the change in
demand for employment advice
there is a big increase in employment
issues in 2020
up by 500.
there has been an increase in the number
of workplace discrimination issues such
as pregnancy and disabilities and these
were particularly profound in march
april may and june of last year as
employers and employees struggled to
deal with the impact of the pandemic on
their businesses
our specialists gave a lot of advice
about well-established employment issues
like redundancy
and also on new areas such as the job
retention scheme
due to our membership this is a vice
network we are able to mobilize very
quickly
and our employment advisors also had
access to specialist teams assistance
advice for more difficult queries
we're under no illusions that the
employment device will be a key service
requirement
for us in the coming months and years
whilst the jobs retention seems
undoubtedly reduced numbers of people
being redundant
it is far from clear how many of those
jobs will still be retained once it ends
next slide
next lie is about debt debt issues are
significantly down for us over the past
12 months
now we don't think this is because there
is less debt we think it's because debt
enforcement has ceased during the
pandemic
as with job retention scheme there have
been a number of protections put in
place
which would include an eviction ban for
renters and payment holidays for credit
cards personal loans and mortgages
some of these have now expired but the
latest england-wide data suggests that
58
of all private renters are now in
arrears
if this figure is correct then clearly
this will not be their only debt
and we already know that council tax
arrears have risen significantly across
both districts since march 2020
once the protections are removed we will
undoubtedly see an increase in the
threat of addiction and homelessness
along with increased numbers of people
unable to
manage their levels of debt the latest
extension to the delayed enforcement
against private renters is only delaying
the inevitable
impacts and outcomes for those who
cannot pay their rent
their advice by its very nature is
complex and incredibly labor intensive
for our specialists
covert has reduced the opportunities to
see people face to face
and therefore we've had to use other
channels such as the telephone to deal
with client issues
this takes us much longer and reduces
the available number of appointments
looking forward trying to forecast
demand for our money advice debt service
will remain a challenge
as a minimum we would anticipate that
once debt enforcement starts again
we will start to see people with debt
issues at least at the same level we did
before the pandemic
however it is reasonable to assume that
we will see an increase in demand
as there are many who pre-pandemic were
able to manage their levels of debt
but now find they no longer do so it is
also reasonable to assume
that we will see far more cases where
urgent immediate action is required
once debt enforcement is allowed to
resume next slide please
this slide seeks to demonstrate the
demand for
food parcels from our local food banks
the use of food banks has increased
dramatically during the pandemic
often used as an economic barometer the
increased demand is clearly linked to
the impact of the pandemic
on individuals and families and shows no
signs of decreasing
across the entire year we have referred
over 50 more clients for a food parcel
as you will be aware many of the food
banks have reported even
even larger increases which is possible
as we are not their only referral agency
through our holistic advice model
clients requesting food parcels
will also be provided with help and
support to tackle other issues such as
the claim of their rights of entitlement
through welfare benefits
debt housing and employment advice
i will now hand over to my colleague
nikki
good afternoon everybody um
nice to have been called back um to see
you all again
even if it is in this strange world um
there was just a couple of bits that i
needed to cover
they asked us what our current
challenges are and
quite frankly we sort of went with the
top three
we've got serious concerns about the
clients who are
digitally challenged in light of the
closure of face-to-face services by all
organizations across the county um
you know give you an example we had a
homeless client who had to borrow
somebody's mobile phone just to call us
there is a whole range of people that
are very much in need of support
which they simply can't access
broadband poverty is a real thing as my
uh darling daughter would say it's a
real thing mum
um poverty hits across
all ages all ethnicities etc
and we've found as i'm sure you all know
about
the schools education not being able to
get online
etc when you've got households that
can't afford
broadband it's as simple as that let
alone those where english isn't perhaps
their first language
or they've got literacy problems or
learning disabilities
so there is a whole portion of society
that we're really concerned
that cannot get support
not only is it about the clients that
can't get the support it's
the client's need for privacy
you know talking about personal issues
especially
when perhaps their financial problems
or you're a victim of domestic violence
you know when they've got children at
home etc
it's not easy it's not always convenient
when people say oh great somebody will
call you back
and you've got two people who are home
schooling or you've potentially in a
domestic violence situation
it's a real concern
the other aspect is the impact the
pandemics had on us
our volunteer our volunteer recruitment
and our volunteer capacity
our volunteers like all other members of
the society have been affected by
shielding
and child care support many of our
volunteers are older people
and haven't wanted to continue
volunteering a lot of people are
reviewing their lifestyle
this is the first time i have ever had
to
employ generalist advisers
to be able to meet the demand that we're
being faced with
you know and i have got a concern that
we'll lose the expertise um
which is very difficult to compensate
for trying
recruiting and training in the pandemic
has not been easy
and getting people to the level of
expertise that's needed to be able to
continue to deliver services
is not a quick and easy you know process
and the last thing was talking about
limitations um like every organisation
um you know we've had to implement
covid's secure working environment
our our premises um
we've had to put in social distancing
measures you know i have crawled around
the floor with two meter tape
and plastic perspex screens
they're not naturally suited to covers
19 resections
with narrow corridors small interview
rooms
some premises are shared with other
tenants etc
and making them safe is a very tall
order and extremely difficult
the immediate need to update our
technology and to be agile has also been
a challenge
and these are sort of some of the
current things that we're facing
especially as
lockdown rules change and we then have
to be able to adapt and move to that
but keeping within all of the
constraints that we've got
so next slide for me is the
question was asked what do we think the
future challenges are
well i'm really worried about the demand
on our services
it feels at the moment
like um pressure that is on family
that is building up and it's
building up for a number of reasons and
we can feel the pressure and it's like a
dam
and this dam is made up with all sorts
of um they're made of decisions it's not
made of the virus
it's made of decisions that have had to
be put in place
to accommodate and support we can feel
the pressure there's a tsunami of debt
the unemployment figures are
eye-watering
breakdown and relationships have been
affected families
and continued cause of stress housing
availability housing issues
education you know some of the decisions
that have been made
in order to support families you know a
ban on bailiff
and enforcement collection of council
tax arrears
the uplift of 20 quid uplift on
universal credit
the extension of furlough arrangements
grants for small businesses
payments for the self-employed
we we thoroughly appreciate some of
the the things that have been put in
place
but we're also good there's also a
concern you know staff have been
redeployed
to deliver these activities to deliver
different covert 19
activities such as stay at home payments
you know they're all excellent
initiatives but while they're doing
those things they haven't necessarily
been doing what they normally would do
so due to the fact that where nothing is
normal you know so that normal council
tax recovery and
rent recovery and all those actions for
the payments aren't
received not you know normal actions
would be to apply for a liability order
from the courts
um which often promotes and encourages
payments to come in
but obviously the that hasn't happened
the courts have a 12-month black backlog
you know when these decisions start
being
you know when this unlocking of these uh
of lockdown happens
and the decisions that have been made
and put in place to support
families start moving
i fear that we can drown in this
tsunami of need and you know and support
that people are going to come out with
because as i say we have no control
over the the flow of the clients
and such big decisions um
when they when they may you know when
they're made or when they change
when they've you know when we get to the
end of march is it then the first of
april that we get
you know 5 000 clients come through the
door in a week rather than 500.
those are the things that are worrying
us um
increased reliance on the voluntary
sector by statutory bodies
we've noticed specifically in the last
12 months
that with face-to-face services closing
down
people working remotely right across the
country
uh right across the county both
districts and at county levels
that um it would appear that you know
we're
we're we are the port of call we're
being you know
told to access through citizens of ice
um some of the closures of face-to-face
services there's no intention of
reopening them again
for all of those clients that can't
access things digitally
i know that that's a concern and a worry
for a number of my colleagues
there's been an additional ask on our
services you know
for we're the gateway for lwa payments
food banks charitable grants they've
we are supporting the county with the
implementation of the sas
suffolk advice and support services line
you know there's been a a heavier
reliance and
ask from the volunt of the voluntary
sector and from citizens by
specifically which i've got a concern
isn't being isn't necessarily being
understood
or supported financially
and talking about money are sustainable
funny
we rely on our core funding to deliver
services and there hasn't been any
that hasn't been increased with
inflation if recovery actions
has not started to be taken from the by
the council
i'm concerned about cash flow
and the impact that that has on your
services to deliver
along with your ability to support us
you know because we know that there is
so much that hasn't you know
that has stopped because of covid
we're also concerned that the additional
funding that was
has been available throughout covert has
been essential to boost
capacity it's not going to be here in 12
months time
although the problems created by the
pandemic
will be here will still be in recovery
for months and months and months
afterwards
people you know managing people who've
got financial problems
benefits issues employment issues all of
those things
aren't magically going to finish on
the 12 months after we got some extra
covid funding
you know the clients are still going to
be there the problems are still going to
be out there
and without sustainable funding to meet
those demands
then you know we're going to be in in a
difficult place
so we want to look to work with the
council to act now
to look at messages of how we ease the
pressure off households and take
steps to start cash flow moving support
houses
households that are facing difficulties
and release the handbrake you know
for whatever phrase and look at what
measures
can be taken in a measured proactive way
to basically to be able to support
things so that we're not
in an all or nothing situation and
the dam breaks and we all drown
so i know it sounds a bit dramatic but
thank you for that
um i think there's one more slide
which just shows how we work together
delivering across the district to and
with your priorities
to build those strong and healthy
communities and
the housings and the assets and all of
those things and how we want to
continue to work with you guys to ensure
that
we get the best for the communities that
we live in
so thank you i'm pretty sure that's the
end of them
so we're up for your questions
well i think the first thing we have to
say is a a big thank you
to colleen simon and nikki for a
very thorough presentation um however
there will be questions
i think that last slide particularly
shows how closely
the aims and objectives of local
citizens advice
align with those of the two councils uh
so i now invite
members of the committee if they have
any questions uh
to the office not in offices the lcas if
they could raise
use the raise hand function and we will
go through them in order
i have councillor scarf first followed
by councillor carter
thank you chair yes um we heard about uh
dis and thetford and um the lack of a
need for outreach at the moment or
they're not able to do an outreach i
wanted is it mid-suffolk ca that have
picked up the work then or
are going to pick up the work that
distant thetford would have previously
done perhaps simon you might be able to
help me with that one
yes councillor well um this and fetford
historically would this and i and
therefore that's why citizens advice
has had that that positioning in the
marketplace in that area of the district
traditionally what's happened is that
this has looked after the northeast
part of the district and has received
funding for that
and they had been delivering a outreach
service at the local gp surgery
at the start of the pandemic that
stopped and that worker their volunteer
has now left their organisation
we we've already in the past 10 months
been working in that area
to put in some different uh projects and
innovations to see if we can
support the community better knowing
that that
advisor had left the area
and they include that we have done some
targeted outreach
we help we are working with a community
resource known as the bank
to provi put in some virtual
advice services um so yes we
mid-south exits advise uh in 21
22 and ongoing will now be
the citizen advice providing the primary
services for this district
thank you simon that's very useful
tonight and if i'm not
mistaken i think there's some crossover
across the norfolk suffolk boundary
between the services provided in norfolk
and those in suffolk and there's a sort
of give and take
is that correct yes we work as a
citizens advice network
yeah what's happened is the chief
officer disinfected
has approached the community's team to
say that
due to the pandemic the footfall that
they normally saw in dis
has not continued and therefore
they felt it not appropriate to continue
making the funding application to mid
suffolk
and informed us of the same decision you
don't turn away somebody from norfolk
and they don't turn away somebody from
suffolk
correct that's fine uh councillor carter
you're up next
would be wonderful could work out how to
do it i'm mute button but we got there
eventually
right um very aware that this is a
thing for questions uh i'm going to
question whether or not a
thank you would be appropriate for how
great the presentation was
it's very thorough and uh
especially thank you to nikki because if
we weren't terrified before her
presentation i think we all
are now um
[Music]
yes and i apologize for the background
noise my daughter is making herself
aware as well
working from home um i'm just assuming
what's your question in there counselor
carter
i did have okay sorry now i can't
remember what i was going to say we
should
blame me i'm going to blame you did you
expect
um yes um i assume
with um as with education uh there's
been a
request for computers uh to be
provided to um to
in education would such a request well
and funding would be a
be a benefit for providing computers to
those who might not have them at home
and is there something we could do with
assistance with uh
funding for internet um
internet supplies and uh would that be
of any benefit
um is that a question for the lcas
uh yes okay any thoughts on that
there are a number of um initiatives and
schemes
in different areas across the county
about supporting people with
um you know laptops and
ipads etc the the problem
is it's it's mainly focused on those
who need it on a sort of a more longer
term basis i.e if you've
if you're homeschooling a child and
that's required but when you're talking
about
just accessing um you know
accessing services to be able to log in
to pay to pay council taxes and things
like that
the equipment is one part of the issue
and the broadband is one part of the
issue
knowing how to use it and having that
support to do it
um i don't you know it's it's having
access
so with things like libraries and things
that have been closed
people could go in and use public um you
know public facilities
that don't have that at home and of
course that hasn't been an option
so i don't think the um supply of
equipment
is necessarily the biggest problem it's
access to it
thank you very much uh councillor muller
i have you next
uh thank you chair it's really just a
follow-up from what uh councillor scarce
asked
a simon you mentioned an innovation
project
can you please give a few more details
about that please thank you
certainly councillor so last year we
became aware of a funding opportunity
through national citizens advice from
the department of business energy
and industrial strategy beis
which was looking for innovative ways of
delivering
access to advice uh so we successfully
successfully bit
into that and receive the sum of funding
which we have used to transform our
virtual access
so as part of that as nikki's just
alluded to there there are a lot of
things going on but one of the things
that we did become aware of is that the
county is running a digital inclusion
group and we became members of that so
we've got
an in on that and there are several
working parties that come
from that what is quite clear is that
the members of the group there's not a
consensus on how it's best to proceed
we had hoped within our innovation
project that we would be able to involve
other partners because we will not be
the only people
that are looking to deliver access to
advice
in a different way and so we had sought
some different partners but that has not
come on board so we've had to
take the ball by the horns and start our
own
so consequently at the moment things
have been
slightly challenging due to the
third lockdown but we will have a device
at the bank in eye and we have 10
sessions booked
10 weeks of sessions booked up there i'm
also very pleased that we've managed to
engage re-engage with watching flying
station and
the welfare team are now also on board
with that
so it's a bit of a plea really because
there's a lot of stakeholders at this
meeting and they know other stakeholders
we believe that in mid-south we can
deliver a quality service
using a virtual device and it's the case
of getting people to that virtual device
and we're also training um volunteers to
be ambassadors
to help people use that device so that's
where we are at the moment we hope to
expand that
and it it's looking like it should be
able to replace
our outreach locations our physical
outreach locations
which means we'll be able to deal with a
lot more people in a far more efficient
way
so that's where we are with our
innovation project at the moment and all
that information is obviously being
shared across
the rest of the suffolk citizens of ice
network because we are a pilot
thank you simon thank you very much
thank you chair thank you thank you very
much
simon thank you councillor muller uh i
suspect that the
demand for uh computers is uh
widespread not least for uh school
pupils uh councillor osborne uh you're
up next
yeah thank you mr chairman uh just uh
two questions really for um
colleen um first of all the
first question is um uh she
we came to a point on the life board
meeting about
a full-time debt advisor acquiring one
can i can i ask how the how that is
going and and
and uh you know how successful
are you at the moment or haven't you
been able to uh look at anybody
and the second one was the the outright
the outreach facility in hadley
um uh the the opportunity i think
for um you to work with that outreach um
again if you could just clarify that
position as well thank you
okay um that advice we know that um
we are as nikki was saying going to be
inundated
um nationally our national organization
actually
of preempting that um demand to increase
by 60
nationally fortunately for us at sudbury
and i think a lot of my
colleagues in other local lcas we were
able to take advantage of
a funding opportunity that came through
um
from the maps money advice and pension
service
via citizens advice that has allowed us
to take on a
trainee debt case worker full-time so
we're we're sort of in the process now
of growing our own
fully trained um up to the level of
court representation
money advice worker specialists so at
the end of that year of funding
we're now looking for how we can retain
and um
develop that and keep that full-time
person along with the part-time
member of staff that we already have so
we're sort of preempting that and
working towards being able to manage
better
the the debt that's going to be coming
through
um does that answer the first question
adrian
yes it does colleen thank you very much
now i like the uh i like the phrase grow
your own
yeah that's what we have to do because
our advisors are so specialist
you know to work in a particular
category and to live
to the qualified level that we need them
to that
we it's very difficult for us to just
put an ad in the paper and get the right
person
usually they've come from the same
background if not our own
our own volunteers become employees um
the second question we were a bit
unfortunate with regards to realizing
ambitions which was a project that
funded um it was a wonderful wonderful
project
and it allowed us to employ um three
very part-time
generalist advisors who would be working
in
outreach locations particularly gp
surgeries across the whole baby district
right down to the shortly
um and the pincilia pin i can never say
that one
that's it that's it and um yes so it
started
it was a large part of funding that was
um
awarded to many organizations all for
very very different things
and that was the basis of our project
was to get the outreach
into the social prescribing world and to
to complement also the connect for
health project that we have in
partnership
with suffolk family carers it was um it
was dead before it started unfortunately
because it all took it all set off just
as the um
pandemic started so our outreach is
obviously the gps weren't seeing
patients themselves
we were as as in our lca we were
actually able to still
give back pretty useful reports on it we
were able to manage it
but also of course with remote advice
but um the whole funding because so many
organizations couldn't manage it
were was not rewarded so it's coming to
an end at the end of march now in answer
to your question
adrian because i'm getting around to
that we started our outreach in hadley
and then
in the um ancill center and then that
was moving into the gp surgery and all
of that
was a pilot for this um project that
we've now lost
but we're certainly there's no way that
we're going to let that go we're going
to
take that back under our core funding so
that we can get back into the outsole
center
and start talking to the gps there too
hadley for us
is essential because we realize we we
just have so much
of our work from hadley and so many of
our clients that wouldn't be able to
access us
face to face without those outreaches so
definitely
i'll be making sure that the the board
understand the importance of getting
that back
into place and hopefully there might be
some funding that comes along to bring
the whole project back into play at some
point
thank you very much uh colleen excellent
presentation to
to all your uh colleagues and yourself
and thank you alistair
thank you thank you we'll move on now to
councillor
young who is the last member of the
committee with these hand-raised so
after that i shall move to
uh questions from any other members
present i do have one so far cancer at
pinyon
thank you chairman um i have two
questions one probably
best addressed to the officers and the
other one
to the team from citizens advice and
as with others i thank you for your fine
presentations
um so for the the citizens advice group
um what are the plans to address
the kind of the recruitment or
replacement of
uh volunteers because obviously that's
the main concern that you have
with a lot of older people disappearing
from your teams
so i i don't hear about what your action
plans are
in that regard and as far as the
the council is concerned there are
broadband companies that are offering
subsidized broadband access and i just
wondered to what extent we're engaging
with those
broadband providers like bt and so forth
to to take advantage of those uh
um offers of subsidized subscriptions
thank you
um if i could just say and i'm sure
simon might want to add the question
that was
directed to us uh we we started off very
well in sudbury we didn't lose people
immediately people
people have drifted off over the past
months
just because things have gone on for too
long and i think the stress on
individuals and
and the anxiety you know it's just
causing people to re-evaluate as nikki
says
um what i do hope is that once we have
come back to a more normal service more
normal world
that i will be able to call on those
people a lot of them may come back to us
um especially if you know i i do a
really emotional
emotional blackmail might might be the
thing that i have to fall back on there
and drill explains them how badly
they're needed they will need a lot of
them um because of the length of time
they've been gone
a small amount of recap training
but other than that we will be
recruiting like mad
um we now are finding that capacity is
an issue where it wasn't for us until
very recently
but hopefully we we can pick that up
we've had recruitment drives in the past
and they've been successful
simon do you like to add to that yeah
well from from our point of view
counsellor um
slightly different uh scenario so as we
kept our advice center open
we were able to keep um more volunteers
engaged
um and that's also not just helped the
organization that's helped some
individuals as well because it's helped
their mental health
by having an outward outlook of
different to being at home
so we have lost a few we have not lost
many but we have recruited a lot
so it's been a quite a fruitful time for
volunteering
in the past 11 months where people have
put themselves up where they might not
have done before
so we currently have 13 volunteers in
training
the problem we have at the moment is
capacity for the training
and delivering of the training because
it is primarily been done virtually
until someone needs to do their
observations
and today we have got three new members
of the 3d volunteers in
who are observing so we have managed to
maintain our recruitment we still
receive
a lot of enquiries and our plans for the
future
are to further develop virtual training
because it will give us a greater pool
of people that we can call on later on
i i probably should add that we we saw
training as being a massive issue
and um which the board just recently
took the um decision
to employ a development training officer
and we've been able to do that
successfully so that will be
simon says a big help thank you very
much for those
answers great i feel
like i was worried was a question for
officers as well in there was there not
there was yes could uh
i don't know if uh corporate manager or
somebody could uh answer that
um i can't answer the questions i'm not
quite aware of maybe the work that has
been taking place but what i can do is
go back to our economic development
colleagues
and find out if they are involved in any
work with our broadband providers and
then come back and provide a
a response at a later date okay is that
happy are you happy with that council
epione
yes chairman i'm happy with that thank
you thank you very much now i know
councillor morley has been incredibly
patient whilst we've been getting
through questions
i do have two more questions hands
raised from members of the committee
so i'd ask you to be patient councillor
mauling with apologies
uh councillor wellam is next followed by
councillor mclaren
and at that point i propose to close
questions from members of the committee
thank you chair um yeah uh
one or two queries around resources um
have the cas been able to produce a
balanced budget for the future year
and are they confident that they'll be
able to do so for the next
three years is financial planning for
the next three years going to be
an almost impossible task is one of the
questions
um the the second is um
have you been able to plan for the
anticipated extra workload
um i've heard um from simon that there
are more volunteers coming on board but
it is um uh are they gonna be
limits to the number of sessions you'll
be able to to to have because of the
the buildings and so on um uh
and is it all budgeted for um and the
third one um
uh great to hear that you're growing
your own
extra staff um but
what is the availability of paid staff
if you need p
paid stuff if you if you've got the
financing you need to bring
staff in are they available should i
start colleen
okay so um
three years ahead and
hopefully uh they're just close
before 2021 2022
and we currently are forecasting in mids
africa 30
000 deficit
primarily our deficit is because
long-term funders are no longer able to
support us to the level that they have
so stone market relief trust have always
given us
a three-year funding grant and that
grant
has been for the past six years fifteen
thousand pounds a year
but because of the demands on their
services because they are being called
upon to give charitable aid on a far
greater extent than ever before
particularly for people moving into
council and local authority housing
and coupled with their own income
reducing
that has now been reduced by two-thirds
there are other charitable organizations
who have not been able to meet
because of um the pandemic as it is at
the moment
or if they have been able to meet they
are in a similar position where they
have reduced income and are no longer
able to support us
i think part of the other thing is are
we comfortable with it i think is that
what i've been asked
we we're never going to be comfortable
with a deficit budget um we were
extremely fortunate last year we
received an awful lot of support
i think my colleagues would agree with
that we received an awful lot of
support but it was all covered related
and if we look this year going ahead
everything that seems to be coming out
is still covered related
or very very very specific
specific groups so that's what we're
finding at the moment
first question from mid-south's point of
view we are forecast the 30 000 deficit
okay so if um i go from now i'm sorry i
might i don't know if it's just me but
i'm having a
it looks like um everybody's cameras
have gone off for me at the moment
so i hope you can hear me okay and see
me um
in sudbury we're in a better position so
we're very fortunate especially now that
we
have heard that we will be receiving
something from um the county council
this um coming year
as we um we've taken that out of our
budget we had a question mark there but
that that will bring us into a more even
position
um in sudbury we've we've over the past
three four years we've worked very hard
to
diversify our funding streams
and in fact um that's that's worked out
well for us so
we um we were in a better position
because those projects some of them are
sort of treating
five year project so we know that those
will continue and and that's been the
sort of planning that's been involved
there um
for to give you an example in 2122
we're looking at the total percentage of
our project funds has been
73 of our total income
but that's not to say that we don't um
still rely
and are grateful for our core funding
because we rely on that very heavily
because
the only the only way to sort of paint a
picture of that is to say
that the project work that we do are the
branches on the tree of core funding
and without the core funding we wouldn't
be able to apply or
be successful in bids for the various
project funding that we have
so we're we're over the next three years
our forecast
is is secure so from our point of view
as colleen says
we've also diversified our income
streams
as far as we can at present one of the
things that's been incredibly beneficial
is the three-year rolling funding
settlement from the district councils
that's helped us go to other funders to
show that we have support the large
funder
for not just the one year um because
there's a lot that are looking for
sustainability
within an organisation before they will
fund and
that's where we are with ours there i'm
sorry counselor i've only i didn't
write down your number two question so
if i go to number three and perhaps
you'd come back to us
so i think the third question was can we
in effect
um use staff
in an increased way to meet resource we
can
but we are a small paid resource we are
more a volunteer organisation
um funding that will be an issue
going forward if we decide that we need
to pay more for our paid staff
to or more resourcing paid staff um
but as greater uh issue
is the fact as colleen has said that we
cannot really advertise
for somebody that is fully trained
because these people do not exist
therefore we have a lead in period but
all i can assure you is that we are
doing everything we possibly can within
the parameters that we know at the
moment
to plan for increased demand
as colleen has said we also applied for
money from the money advice and pension
service to provide
a debt advisor on a full-time basis and
we're successful
so we have increased our our debt
resource
three-fold so all we can do now is just
look at what's coming over the horizon
and try and plan accordingly and um
be as prudent as we can with the money
that we receive
i do apologize i can't remember what the
second question was all right
i must confess nor can i cancel epinone
could you uh maybe repeat your second
question unless somebody else has
already got the answer handy
i'm sorry too i think it was
councilwellum
and i think it was something along the
lines of you've been able to plan for
the extra workload
um well i think yes sorry to interrupt
me i think i think simon answered
questions two and three together
so that's that's great i think all my
queries have been answered
can i i'd like to also add uh in support
of simon's comments about the three year
funding that that has made a tremendous
difference to our security and allows us
to plan
for the next three years at least so
really grateful for that
that was very much the hope when we did
the job it does it makes such a
difference
really can i just briefly intercede
there that uh
has that experience of the
multi-authority
uh task and finish group has that fed
into
your funding on a wider level across the
county
um yes we've used some of the some of
the quotes and comments from that on
occasion
fine that's okay it's just it's nice to
know that these things are worthwhile
and i know are still appreciated it was
not intended to be a one-off report it
was
intended to actually provide a steer for
multiple authorities
over a period of years uh councillor
mclaren
is the last member of the committee with
a question i believe yes and it will go
to other members
thank you chair uh my questions
addressed to colleen actually
um i was very um
impressed that you mentioned shortly
peninsula
uh we often i'm a ward member on the
peninsula
and it's in a difficult situation to
access
uh if people don't have public transport
um so thank you for that consideration
of the peninsula
we just hope that you can develop your
program
the other thing was that you mentioned
social prescribing i'm a great supporter
of social prescribing
i support the person that works on the
peninsula
completely and that is the way to go
so in your opinion if you were looking
at some sort of service
on the peninsula what
what sort of cost would that be
sort of i'm not wanting precise costs
but
it might be something that we ought to
work towards
it would be difficult without putting
the whole project plan together and
looking at the you know
even if you looked at the salary and the
capital costs it it would be difficult
without looking at
how many hours you'd be offering an
employee a week you know
the area that you'd be how many um
face to face or or telephone hours you'd
be offering clients so
that would be something but i do hope um
councilman clarin that
we we can get that one back off the
ground it's one that i'm very keen on
so and um i know that nikki nikki um
has um social prescribers or and
in the ipswich area that complement
the the service complements we've got in
sudbury we've got
the connect for health person that goes
right across faber
the young woman in um that area is
called hayley
i don't know if that's who you're
referring yes yes
she works very close with our um our
employees sophie
who has the other half of baby but to my
mind
the the perfect service adds general
advice
from citizens advice into the mix so
you've got
poulting you've got the social
prescriber or community connector
so many people use social prescriber for
different there are so many different
models
but community connectors are looking
after the health and well-being
but then referring into our generalist
advisors
so our project was to marry up with the
community connectors
and provide the practical advice side
and that that that would have given each
each area in the baby district the whole
holistic service so perhaps could uh
because i am really interested in that
and its development
uh i'd be very grateful if at some point
when you're considering it
um you know i'd like to be kept in the
loop if so
certainly
[Music]
it's only just coming to an end at the
end of march and we'll be looking for
something to support it further but
it's not something we're going to let go
thank you colleen thank you chair
not so much thank you council mclaren i
think it's fair to say that a great deal
of stuff is still going to be up in the
air for some time to come
now we'll move on to a very patient
councillor morley
thank you thank you very much chair i'm
i'm really grateful for allowing you to
ask a question and it relates to
funding and um thank you
very much to simon colleen and nikki i
really appreciate all that information
that you've just given us
um on the funding side on our paper
page four where you're talking about
financial implications
um mid suffolk and and baba both fund
mid suffolk um citizens vice and weber
citizens advice but we also fund
west suffolk and ipswich and i'm just
wondering to what extent
do west suffolk fund
our cabs and also
do ipswich borough make any contribution
to our
lcabs from sudbury
not to sudbury um ipswich borough
um just are very supportive of citizens
of ice and ipswich
i've had a three-year deal with them
for the past three years um
please now i only have to apply once
every three years
it works slightly differently but
as i say again that's not index links
that hasn't
that hasn't gone up what has happened is
ipswich has expanded beyond its
boundaries
um over the last you know
over the last few years and continues to
do so so there are
parts of um mid suffolk
and baber that um use its fit services
and facilities the one that i'm really
quite
um disappointed in more than anything
else
is our um east suffolk colleagues
um the old stuff at coastal especially
for
the amount of clients that we support
around the kesgrave
um the the kesgrave areas and martelsham
areas
which technically fall into suffolk
coastal
and um they don't show any support or
financial support whatsoever towards
ipswich but as i say a percentage
of um the clients that we see
um are from mid-suffolk and baber and
we're very grateful for the support that
you give
from a mid-suffolk point of view we
receive no funding from west suffolk
um so we we received no funding from
west southwest i think it's fair to say
that i mean nikki's mentioned there that
ipswich has joined its borders but just
for every everybody present the meeting
so we're all clear
we are a network across suffolk so we
all see
each other's clients from time to time
so mid suffolk sees proportion of
ipswich
and ipswich will see proportion of
mid-suffolk and likewise for baber
and the same does apply for west suffolk
what we don't want is we don't want to
get into a post a postcode
situation due to funding because that
does not help the client no
i accept that we we are
a network and i'm just trying to
understand the extent to which
you know mid-suffolk fund
put money towards ipswich cab
which don't put money towards our cab
i'm just trying to understand that
relationship that's all
i know i know to councillor morley that
uh that tom barker has his hand raised
he may have something to add at this
point
um thank you councilman yes if i can
just come in
conscious that we're in a in a period
whereby the questions are for the
citizens advice themselves and
um nikki wilshere provided an answer in
terms of the ipswich
citizens advice but as um councilor
morley has kind of
re-explained i think her question was
not so much about
what ipswich gets from ipswich or what
mid suffolk gets from in suffolk but
whether because baber and mid suffolk
are both funding outside of district
whether each of those citizens advice
get any funding
from outside of district and simon
talked about it being a kind of
suffolk system whereby um
there's a recognition that ipswich ca
might get mid-suffolk residents but
equally mid-suffolk cia might get
ipswich or residents from and edmonds or
where else it might be depend on where
people
work and all the rest of it and i
suppose i i just wondered a question
perhaps to
to simon and colleen was whether you
have made funding applications
to either west suffolk council or
ipswich borough council and had those
rebuffed or whether you just simply
haven't made the applications
um i think before my time there may have
been applications but
not not in the five years that i've been
in sudbury and and we don't receive from
anybody other than our own
county and local district authorities
we don't make an application to ipswich
borough and
uh west suffolks is via a community
chest
by which we're not invited to apply
i think at this point i should maybe
mention and i think all this stuff is
incredibly interesting but of course
we are here to deal with the uh funding
provided by baba and mid suffolk
district council
we should concentrate on that because
that is what we have any direct
influence over
uh sorry tommy did you have something
i've got wrong there
no no no not at all you're you're
absolutely right i wondered whether
um as officers we should
should take away to have a conversation
with ipswich borough
and with west suffolk um at an officer
level
to have a have a conversation with their
teams to see whether there would be a
um a means through which we could seek
some
yeah i don't know quid pro quo i suppose
i've got your idea there colleen do you
have a thought on that just to say we
could support that would appreciate and
we could support it with
um statistics and i will just add from
this committee's point of view that it's
entirely in keeping with the
multi-authority task and finish group
approach that was made
uh at the end of the last year or sort
of at the crossover between two years
um that produced the recommendations
this committee gave
last year councillor morley uh have your
questions been answered
they have indeed thank you so much thank
you very much we now move to councillor
ayers who will be
i think the last questioner in what's
been a rather extensive questioning
session
counselor ayers thank you chair um no
i'd just like to say it's
um thank you again colleen who i've
known for years because i support you
from sudbury down
um it's interesting that you were saying
how so many of the um
the elderly needed face to face
and when you will be able to do it
because as you know sadly we're using
losing our access point um from five
days a week
to two days a week which i'm really not
happy about as everyone's
fully aware um but um i just wondered
when you'll be able to have face to face
because
it is so important particularly for the
elderly that's it you know the
disadvantaged
and thank you for your presentation but
is a big concern of mine
because some of these people will never
ever we've been told
oh it's a digital you know everything's
going digital
um but i don't think it's going to
happen to some of them
sadly i think nikki's explained that sue
and it's not only the the actual
physical equipment is the
the ability to to use it
um when we can go back to face-to-face
oh i hope it's next week but
it's not looking good but let's hope
it's not too long and now
and a lot of our people are very keen
and now having you know the jabs now and
hopefully things aren't are coming out
of the other end
but um what we've all done is we've set
up these virtual interviews in our
offices
so that's a little bit more covered
secure
and what we can do in those sort of um
interactions with clients who would
struggle themselves is talk them through
the use of the equipment that we're
putting them in front of so we can
actually have a printer and scanner in
the room where things are being printed
out for them and
somebody will be talking to them and
looking at what you know what they're
doing
the the whole setup the interview will
be set up when they sit down in the
chair
so that's that's the the best idea that
i think all three of us have got at the
moment for that yeah
and of course as soon as um face-to-face
services can be resumed
as i was saying earlier there's a little
bit the differentials are with regards
to the the office space that we have and
how we can use them
we have two interview rooms that we will
be able to use initially
face to face because they're they're the
ones that we don't have to go through
the corridor to and
you can get people in there without
traveling all around the building and i
think the setup's the same for my
colleagues too that identified the rooms
that aren't the best
well sadly sadly colleen we haven't got
that in the library because i was a
meeting on friday afternoon
and these people some of them do need
that
and that their privacy because of their
problems
and also yeah we've been open all the
way through
all the way through covid um we've been
open
for those desperate people who we really
do care about but thank you colleen
thank you
not at all so thank you councillor i
think we're a little bit in danger of
extending beyond our remit here now i
note council carter has his hand raised
but i was prepared to
close off questions unless unless your
question is something so dramatic
counselor carter that you need to raise
it now
i can make the suggestion off meeting
and i'll um
i'll allow for the process thank you i'm
just aware that time is pressing and
we have covered a great deal of ground
my thanks to everybody involved in the
questions
uh at this point we've gone through the
questions i'll now
open the item up for debate on both the
report
and the presentation if members could
use the raised hand function
would anybody like to kick off
well i'd just like to raise one point
and it does address the elephant in the
room
um in that the recommendation made by
this committee
um last year into last year's cabinets
was that not only a three-year rolling
arrangement be made with the lcas
but also that it should be index linked
now
in all the fuss and bother around
uh this last year we were reviewing the
citizen's advice
rather later in the year than we would
otherwise
and it became apparent that uh the
proposed sums
were in fact exactly the same as the
previous financial year
i raised this point at the babera
cabinet and i don't know if councillor
welland was able to do so
with the mid-suffolk cabinet that it had
been the intention and recommendation
that a index linking now be applied
i received an informal acknowledgement
of that both from officers and the
cabinet members
at the bayboro cabinet meeting to the
extent that where finance is allowed
that it could be
accommodated within the final budget
that we'll be voting upon
in our respective councils next week
so we received a preliminary this is
myself and the council of welum as
chairs
indication that a index linking of
approximately one percent might be
applied now i have to say
one percent is obviously better than
nothing but it doesn't seem to be a
great deal of index linking
so i would like to suggest that perhaps
uh obviously we're quite happy with the
recommendation in the report up to that
point but
i believe we should still address the
index linking that we'd originally
recommended last year
that's consistent with what we've done
before can i hear any thoughts from
members
on that point
council scarf uh yes joe i think your
point is a very valid one and
i i would suggest perhaps that the one
percent is a little bit parsimonious
i would have thought that we would be
looking nearer to two percent
um as a a suggestion i would be happy
uh to support you if you're wishing to
propose a motion
or anything in terms of a slightly
higher increase
than that it's for others to decide but
obviously i think it's for us to
suggest that they may uh decide i i also
have a further point
which if you'll come back to me a little
later chair thank you
yes if you can i'd like to deal with
this issue for the first moment i see
tom barker has his hand raised tom um as
communities is
very very much in your belly wick what
would you say on this
um i'm conscious and thank you
councilman
conscious that you're in debate and it's
not really um probably my place to
step in on that debate but i just
thought in on this point
um you've got an item later on the
agenda that provides you with an update
on the grants review
um and that that discusses moving to
a kind of two phase grants review
whereby in the first phase we looked at
capital grants and minor grants and the
second phase would be looking at revenue
and i did just i i suppose my my
instinct is that
um all of our revenue grant recipients
are equally important and provides a
fantastic benefit to
the communities that they serve and on a
kind of
fair and equitable basis i wonder
whether you wanted to build the
inflationary increases
into phase two of the revenue grant
review
rather than dealing with the ad hoc
relation relating to the citizens advice
and then other revenue grant recipients
as part of that grant review
so i just thought i'd let you know that
that point could potentially be covered
um on the the item that you've got
around
the update to the grants review well it
is i take your point
tom it's a very good one but i note that
in the report
from front of us we do have um
a suggestion 11 consultations ongoing
dialogue continues with all cas
as part of the grants performance
framework i believe that's what you're
referring to
here uh i was
yeah referring to the well that as part
of the grants framework we have an
ongoing dialogue with our grants
recipients
and as such we're in constant
conversation with the citizens advice
but
running separately from that there is a
member working group comprised of
um two councillors from baber two
councillors from mid-suffolk
um so as councillor davis and councillor
carpendale i believe from baber and
um councillor flatman and councillor
wellam from mid-suffolk who are looking
at the
the grants process and we'll be looking
at revenue grants
um imminently that that process has been
delayed a little bit
um because of responding to the code
pandemic but
that grants review is is separate from
the ongoing dialogue that we have with
grants recipients
and that grants review would feed into
um
looking at amendments to the process
that we use for our revenue grant
i appreciate that's a possible route tom
it's it's a point but i mean i'm i'm
keen that we should actually be
consistent
in the recommendations that the
committee have made and having made a
com
a recommendation from this committee in
a previous year i believe we should be
consistent with that
uh councilor mclaren and then councillor
wellam
thank you chair um i just wanted to
support what you were
you were suggesting um
because we have listened to a service
this afternoon
that really needs to have the facility
to develop
that there's lots of work out there so i
i think
for some increase on a regular basis
should be considered i'm not going to
say what percent that might get me into
trouble but
um i think it should i'm fully
supporting
your proposal well on the on the level
we're talking about
one percent uh will be representing not
thousands but hundreds of pounds so
we're not exactly talking about
it it's a start uh but i think it's
important to just get this into
perspective and i know that
finances are always tight but where
small surpluses are forecast
in a budget i think it's allowable to
make the suggestion that the index
linking that this
committee recommended last year be
continued councillor wellam
it's their safety chair it's very
difficult to know what it should be
index
linked to because yeah we often link
things to cpi
but when when cpi uh
is very low demand upon
ca is probably very high and we can't
very well have it
an indirectly proportional index linking
but i i do think that i do think that
something like two or three percent
would be reasonable for the current
uh for the for the next three year
period and and then
who knows what after three years the
recommendation was that that
index linking the subject and part of
the annual review
which uh in the baby case in in
actual fact was a job given to us by the
baba cabinet that is for the baba
committee members we were specifically
charged with that review function um
having been charged with it i believe we
should endeavor to fulfill that
responsibility
so i would like to propose an amendment
to the recommendations
that states that we confirm
our previous resolution of the last
review that the three-year
review figures be subject to
and i think all we can say at this stage
is indexation
to be determined and obviously with
reference to
finances available i think we're all
understanding of that point
but i think the point should be made in
a recommendation
so that's what i'm proposing uh
henrietta would you ha
i'm proposing that henrietta would you
have a form of words that i've just
given that would be appropriate there
hello you apologize i shall put camera
sorry it's okay sorry um
i might need to get your wording again a
little bit but um
we confirm the recommendation previously
made
uh the previous review that
the three-year rolling review be subject
to
indexation on an annual basis
yeah finances
permitting one moment please
uh finance permitting finance is
permitting
as a measure of the importance
we attach to lca funding
ongoing lca funding
sorry to attach
measure importance we attached
to the
funding all right let me just get that
can you read that back
can we have that just one moment check
just give me two minutes
i'll come to your second councillor
scarf okay
right so we have
that the joint over you and scrutiny
committee confirmed the previous
resolution
of the previous recommendations that the
three-year rolling review
rolling funding
is subject to indexation finances
permitted
as measure of importance we attach to
the ongoing
funding can you add in after indexation
on an annual review basis
yes let's leave flexibility in there
were you wishing to second or did you
have a point point to mike yes joe i
would be very happy to second that
thank you certainly
uh would you like me to put this in the
chat function or you're happy for me to
read it loud again
a little no i think we have the essence
of it a little more discussions
members um
and then i'll address a query
you had some doubt as to what part of
the
debate you'd have been able to follow
i'm not sure we can get councillor
grandin in at the moment
maybe that councillor grandin is having
some difficulties chair i've noticed
that
um the uh that jan robinson the
um corporate manager for law and
governance has
asked to speak yes certainly jan
thank you chair just to clarify um
councillors um
only need to be in the room for the
whole of regulatory committee so that
applies to planning and licensing
council crandon can vote but needs to be
pretty
sure that she has understood and heard
enough of the argument to be able to
to take a decision on that okay i think
i think that's fairly clear councillor
wellam
thank you chair um well let me just
switch the video on it won't
okay we can hear you um yeah
one of the things which i should have
asked about um when we were
when we were asking questions was about
the role of observer
um it's very good to have the uh
the annual review that we're having
today that's true that's really useful
and we've
learned a lot from it um but uh i
understood from what um
councillor osborne has said in the past
that um
his role as um the observer appointed by
baba district council is very useful to
the district council
and to ca i just wondered if
it was possible to um to ask
uh the um ca offices from
sudbury and from mid suffolk firstly um
whether
it is useful having an observer to hear
from colleen
and for simon to tell us whether or not
he would welcome
an observer now that formed very much
part of our recommendations when we were
reviewing participation
on appointed outside bodies so
technically it doesn't fall within but i
would be interested
if you could briefly answer please uh
because a yes or a no
or something very short because uh time
is wearing on
okay um i'd say and i i'm pleased to
know that um councillor
osborne agrees that we think that's a
very positive arrangement
completely positive can't think of any
negatives there at all
um councillor rob osborne is able to um
advise us about various project schemes
things that may be of interest where we
can support the local authority
and equally i think that he has a really
good understanding and insight into
who we are and what we do and and we're
heading for
and he's always been completely
supportive of us and yeah
no negatives all positive we just hope
that mid-suffolk
officers and cabinet members will take
note of that and it was of course a
recommendation
out of our review of outside bodies
thank you very much colleen
uh any more debate from members please
at this point
i'd just like to thank colleen for her
words here i'm
very embarrassed about that
none of us had any doubt about it that's
not at all
councillor scarf you have your hand
raised
uh yes thank you chair um well the
recommendation we've got in 3.1 i think
really um doesn't go quite far enough
in uh recommending uh
from our committee that we heartly
endorse i think the contribution made by
citizens advice that's very evident from
today's meeting and all of the previous
meetings that we've had
and the recommendation 3.1 is just to
note the report which
doesn't really go far enough i feel um
i think words can't describe how
i think the committee feel about ca's uh
involvement
on behalf of our residents so i wondered
if we could uh
perhaps include something like that i
appreciate it's very difficult to do it
in an electronic vote very quickly but
something along those lines
that we commend the work of ca as
fulfilling
uh the
uh the points made in the reason for the
decision perhaps if the reason for the
decision
could be uh made 3.1 that we are
satisfied
that citizens advice etc etc and then
we're not just noting it we are
confirming that
as a positive so 3.1 would then read
uh the overview and scrutiny committee
are satisfied
etc i think that's that's very good
uh and we commend and we commend the
work
of lcas that we contribute to
indeed and then 3.2 as i've recommended
has also
stressed the importance that we attach
to the work
of the lcas would that be sufficient
councillor scuff
yes that certainly would um i'm happy
i'm happy to make the proposal and carry
on with your seconding of that if you
would i will
i think that's a form of wording that
covers most people's views
counselor muller yes thank you chair um
could we just have simon simon's comment
about an observer at the mid-suffolk
citizens advice trustee board meetings
please chair
thank you from a midsurfing point of
view
we have no issues whatsoever um our
colleagues tell us it's positive why
would we say no
thank you very much simon i think that
confirmation is
all that is required so members if
unless there are any other points of
debate
or anything else to discuss i would like
to propose we move to the vote
chair i have it i have another issue
which i referred to
earlier um apologies cameron
this would be a matter that would just
affect mid suffolk overview and scrutiny
committee members it has no
uh bearing on baba members
so it would have to be dealt with
separately but i'm wondering bearing in
mind
what we've heard um about mid-suffolk ca
taking over effectively the coverage
area for dis and thetford
um with its outreach whether we should
look at
um reallocating the sum of money which i
believe
is in the budget uh for mid suffolk
uh from distant thetford for this
particular year
only uh to mid suffolk cia
it appears that they are going to pick
up the responsibility
and indeed the costs associated with
um and i wanted to move a motion that
reflected that
um conscious of the fact that only um
applies to mid-suffolk's
scrutiny committee um i wondered if you
could rule perhaps
on how we might be able to do that well
the first thing is to establish whether
that is in fact the case
that the responsibility is being
transferred because i got the impression
it was one of the two-way process the
figure
mentioned here amount awarded 2020 to 21
is 8 810 pounds uh do we have
confirmation that that is what is
was proposed or is included in the
budget for 2021-22
can an officer help with us for that
vicky um
yeah sorry i'll saw tom's handle up but
that is currently in the budget for
2122. if uh dis stepford and district ca
do not require that money the proposal
then
would be that that money be transferred
to the mid-suffolk ca
is that correct councillor scarf that's
absolutely correct chad
okay that would be a separate
recommendation for the mid-suffolk
members would require a proposal under
secondary
i think it's a valid recommendation
mr tom barker um
yes sorry just on a point of procedure i
suppose um
the revenue grants are delegated to
officers within budget
so um the the
previously the the ons reports
um went to cabinet because the
three-year rolling arrangement
wasn't something that was in our kind of
grant processes and procedures so that
was a departure and so
so cabinet reflected on that and um and
looked at it
the allocation of grant monies within
the overall
grants envelope um
so the the within the budget setting we
have an overall grants part
and that overall grants part is proposed
to carry forward for next year
so i wonder whether you'd like to leave
it for officers to discuss with
this and thetford and stone market
citizens advice
and subject to disinfect food kind of
withdrawing
where the stone market amends their
application that they've made to us by
an amount equivalent to the sum that
this and thetford were going to receive
and then we can simply deal with that at
an officer level
um within the allocations bearing in
mind of course the
clear steer that we've we've had from
from this committee
i wonder if that's the the most kind of
straightforward
procedure effectively we're being asked
here if we are prepared
to provide that steer and a clear
direction
for officers and delegate the authority
to officers
in conjunction with the lcas to come to
an arrangement
would that be sufficient i think that's
an eminently sensible suggestion chair
it leaves the final decision to the
officers and gives them the flexibility
that they may require
uh to deal with distance but the
intention however is
that any monies that are unspent in the
budget
are actually transferred uh to the cas
as and when and each of them require so
i think that that adequately covers it
thank you chair
in that case i don't know that that
necessarily requires a recommendation
uh the message has been sent received
and understood
so i propose for the simplicity of the
time scale involved that we just allow
that to go forward as discussed now
thank you that's great i think we can
now go to the vote which we applying to
both councils on the two resolutions
i believe councillor brandon had queries
whether she
had been it was able to vote it's my
understanding from
uh the uh corporate manager jan robinson
that that
is the case she's understood the nature
of the debate
heard the presentations and this is not
one of those
committees where there is a question
about having to be present for every
second of
the meeting so yes councillor grandin
you may vote
uh so uh hand over to the governance
officer henrietta would you like to
start the vote please yes chair um our
members in agreement of the
recommendation do everybody understand
them
i believe so we've wrapped them ready
that's fine i'm just making sure
i think even with the possibility of
some
minor wordings the intent is absolutely
clear
that's fine let's go so the vote is in
progress
and the blue line it's further down the
page so you may have to
hover to get the line to thicken so you
can reach it
chair so uh
we have everybody has voted and it is 12
votes for
thank you so that is carried and will be
sent forward where it's required to be
sent
thank you very much members thank you
very much for the representatives of the
lcas colleen simon and nikki
thank you to officers an extensive uh
coverage of the subject although we
could have gone on a lot longer there is
so much to do
item 12 on the agenda is an information
bulletin
now this information bulletin contains
responses raised at the baber overview
and scrutiny committee meeting in
january
but includes information for both
councils
it arises out of a question uh raised in
the chairs briefing from
sorry arising from that meeting and a
table paper was agreed to be produced
for this meeting
in the chairs briefing from lee crowdell
the tenant service
corporate manager if members have any
questions upon these specifics in this
i'd ask them to address them to the uh
the same yeah the government's officer
and responses will be provided outside
the meeting this is merely for
information
but that since it arose out of the
meeting we thought it should be returned
to the meeting chair mary
yes by all means just to let me know
there was actually a
supplement paper published earlier this
morning
explaining further some of the queries
that
was on the paper um at the chairs
briefing so there are actually
in fact two information bulletins at the
moment if members can note
both those papers the original android
addendum
uh and raise any questions they have
through the governance officer
um it may result in something further in
the future
but not today okay
item 13 is a community grants
review update i'm just trying to find
the page uh
where which paper would that be in
henrietta
is that in the chair we do not have a
paper for this one this will be a
presentation
thank you very much in that case i'd ask
for the presentation to be delivered by
vicky i imagine
thank you henriette is it yourself or um
myself who's going to share that
presentation
would you share it um i can share if you
want i just need to find it
i didn't wasn't aware one moment please
that's okay
i think once the presentation is um
being found that the last tasking
task and finish group which is a a
counsellor task and finished group
looking at the community
grants programme it was felt appropriate
that we just updated ourselves on
progress made with regards to the
the grants review like tom's alluded to
earlier on
um in this session the review is divided
into two
phases phase one was very much looking
at the capital grants both minor
and major capital grants and uh second
phase is looking into
the revenue um grants um so we have all
but
concluded the capital grants or albeit
some work is still ongoing
um and we have just uh agreed
a scoping document for the second phase
and that will begin
as soon as we possibly can we've got a
bit of clash of priorities at the moment
so
as soon as we can start on phase two of
the review we will
thank you i think that's pretty much
covered everything um
are there any questions on the community
grants review update
do we is there a presentation or
there isn't it doesn't seem to be a
presentation yet i don't know if we're
going to have to defer this here it
comes
i will be brief if you like checks i
recognize the
time um we have some time constraints
yes yes
so in effect what i've done in this
particular presentation is i've added
the first two slides are literally just
what we've uh managed to complete with
regards to the grants review
the second slide uh second set of slides
which are just about how we've
managed to spend the both the catalan
revenue grants over this last financial
year
i'm more than happy that you just take
those away and if anybody's got any um
specific questions about those i'd happy
to answer those outside of this meeting
um but in terms of the the community
grants
review so far um we've just
we've had a look at what we have
currently produced over the last few
years
and in no particular order the types of
things that we've made some improvements
on are things like kpis monitoring and
managing better all of our capital
grants
and actually being in a position whereby
we have an appreciation of what
we have typically spent and supported
over the last few years
also to keep a really watchful eye over
the types of applications that coming
through into the team as we progress
through the year so we can actually do
some profiling of our grants funding um
as well um we've also included kpis and
amended some of our processes so that we
can
look at the types of projects that we
are supporting as well so we're
developing some
key performance indicators around how
our capsule grants are supporting
different types of projects whether they
be well-being projects projects for
younger people projects for older people
active living so we can actually start
profiling and act and then map that
across our two districts as to
where predominantly some of those
activities and
and projects are taking place so we can
see where the bulk of our
finances are are going and where we
might see some some quiet areas
we'll do some proactive um advertising
or corrupt or ground schemes
to actively pursue projects or
place-based projects in those areas
we've also made some changes to the sort
of guns policies
um we were providing um a third of
project costs
or to a maximum 25 000 pounds over three
years
we've changed that slightly to reflect
that um we do
expect applicant organizations to
contribute 10
of project um project costs so that was
40
provided by a grant kind of sort of
brings them up to that magic percentage
of um
50 which we know is seen as a bit of a
test bed for the viability of projects
uh to other external funders so we've so
it just kind of makes it easier for them
to access other external
sort of resources and make those
projects seem more viable
so we've done that but also we have
responded to the council's declaration
of climate emergencies and
inc included that contribution
or to 50 to those projects which are
showing that they are making a number of
engine efficiency
improvements to any of their within any
of their projects so
village halls including solar panels so
to speak
in some of their redevelopment projects
um
we've looked at the priorities for grant
funding as well
and a number of the priorities that were
uh being used to
allocate particular grants were outdated
and linked to the
the old strategic plan so we've now kind
of revised that created a new mission
statement
as well as a number of different
priorities that encompass all the the
new policy documents
like such as the community strategy that
underpin the the
joint corporate plan so we've just
brought those more up to date as well
and made sure that
those priorities um for baby suffolk are
also aligned which before they
they weren't um we've also made a few
changes to locality award terms and
conditions and that's more about
creating
flexibility um in terms of what
the the funding can be can be used for
and josh and the team has set um a
number of sort of
created number of presentations to uh to
to train councils in what that that
funding can be
used for i think that there's been a
great
a greater degree of use of that funding
obviously in miss suffolk but we felt
with babera for coming on board this
year with um locality awards it was
just worthwhile to take the opportunity
to look at what the
the criteria was around that and make an
amendment now and then to
share that learning and sort of training
programs with
all counsellors
and we've updated and sort of slim lined
the processes
with regard to our grants uh processes
so currently there there is two forms
and we've now slimlined them so there's
one so we have one form which
all organizations had to provide their
own details and there was a phase two
part two
report that they had to also complete
which then detailed all their project
details and both forms
repeated a level of information so we've
managed to condense those and make them
a lot easier
they will also be digitalized or
digitized and used on our website as
well so it makes it easier for the
applicants to complete those they'll
also be and the data that's stored in
there will also be
easier for us to access and do some
mapping with that information so we can
always do some
better searches because at the moment
when we want to search on particular
applicants it's a really quite heavy
duty spreadsheet that we have to look
through so we're just trying to
modernize our processes but very much
accept that um
whilst we digitalize we've heard through
the conversations with the cas today we
don't want to leave anybody behind in
that respect so
whereby people still need to um have
written
paper applications that we still manage
to we
will still support groups to complete
those and we will do the behind the
scenes updating of
various um digitized forms we also
appreciate that
um there is going to be an increase in
demand for some of our grants
um in the coming years uh we
on the some of the slides that will come
after this particular
later in this presentation we there's a
clear uh line
particularly in the major capital grants
where we are seeing a much greater spend
and that's
primarily because our grants team are
being far more proactive than they ever
have been
in ensuring that we support community
grants however
we also appreciate there is a going to
be a greater demand for some of our
funding therefore we have
developed this scoring matrix to better
equip our team
um to both through sort of transparency
and fairness
be able to um judge on you know each
project on that on their merits um
uh so that if we are ever challenged as
we go forward we have we've got a very
open and transparent process that we can
share with people and
and kind of feedback as to why projects
were or weren't
weren't successful and that's been
missing from the grants program at them
up to now um
we've also talked about publishing
locality awards spins
on our website i know the county council
do that very regularly but
we're proposing that for the time being
we we do it at the end of each financial
year
and we've also created new
grants databases which are being
developed as we speak
and again touching on what i've talked
about earlier on this will provide us a
much better tracking and mapping of our
grants so
like i said earlier where we can see
then where the grants are being spent in
our in our chatristics
what kind what level of spend is being
um allocated and for what types of
projects
are being spent and we'll kind of map
that against what we know our community
needs where our community assets are
and make sure that you know whatever we
are doing is as fair as it possibly can
can be so in terms of the community
grants i think
uh henry if you can move forward on the
slides
yeah that's pretty much where we're at
with the um
with the capital side of the grants
review
like i said we are now moving on to the
revenue side
of um the the reviewer by we will be
looking at all of our processes all of
those applications and organizations
that come
for funding each year and just doing a
thorough review of
what it is that we're funding whether
they meet our corporate priorities
and how we can better support some of
those groups with different ways of
working with us
seeking a further additional funding for
them
but also we we know that when um
applicants often apply for revenue
funding in amongst all of the work
they're doing there are pockets of
capital funding so it might be that we
can redirect
some of those awards to the capital
parts as opposed to revenue funding
so that we can try and make our pennies
go go further
i don't know how you feel about me
continuing with the rest of the
presentation because the rest of the
presentation isn't
quite what was asked for it's more about
the spend
um that's been allocated this financial
year like i say i'm more than happy to
talk right through the slide
i think vicky i mean effectively this is
an information
update um and of course i think members
should be advised
that this is after all uh the subject of
the work of the grants review
task and finish group and there is
little point in our duplicating or
attempting to duplicate their work
this i would say has been the year of
the grant uh for one reason or another
from
government central government from this
uh aspect of local government from all
over the place
uh i can only commend and
thank congratulate the community's team
and indeed all the other people they
drafted in
in the course of the last year in
distributing the grants as quickly and
efficiently
as they did i mean it's rarely been seen
for local government to be moving
so quickly and so responsively and i
think that's
often been overlooked as we've got used
to the system of the changes in the
world in the last year
that we've forgotten just how fast the
council was
when things looked really bad uh back in
march and the summer of last year
so congratulations to the communities
team and all officers involved
in grants if members do have any
questions um
perhaps they could hold them to the task
and finish group
or officers i'd note councillor morley
wished to say something there
um councilor morley oh hey councillor
flatman i apologize councillor flatman
as you're the cabinet member thank you
very much
chair for letting me speak because i
know you're in a in a rush
um i just i'd just like to thank the
communities team this has been a very
difficult year for them and they have
been
absolutely brilliant in everything
they've they've produced i mean to carry
on with these um reviews and things at
such a difficult time
and i'd like to thank the task and
finish group who have put such a lot of
work into
but you know they have just been
brilliant the
the community's team absolutely
brilliant and thank you to all the staff
ricky
thank you yeah there have there have
been i'm speaking for myself here but i
hope for a number of other members there
are times where it's
uh difficult to be a counsellor but
though this it's been a real pleasure to
be proud
of the work carried out by the council
on
on residents behalf whether it be
appreciated or not it certainly has been
appreciated by a number of
my residents and and the people i know
uh can we now move on though
thanks have been noted uh we'll move on
to the item 14 which is the forthcoming
decision list
do members have any comment on the
forthcoming decision list which is
circulated to all councillors every week
okay in that case it's just for noting
and of course any point can be raised
during the week
itself items 15 and 16
are the baber and mid suffolk overview
and scrutiny
work plans does anybody have any
comments you will note
that the um meeting of the uh
19th of april is blank because we will
be in a pre-election period
and it is not going to be appropriate to
holding meetings at that time
the rest of the um
work plan for the year is fairly clear
and obviously
a new work plan will be shortly prepared
towards the end of this calendar year
any comments anybody
please use the raised hand function
otherwise uh they are for noting
and with that the meeting is concluded
my
thanks to all members for a lengthy but
i think
comprehensive study of the subject the
next
joint overview and scrutiny committee
meeting will be on monday the 22nd
of march uh 9 30 a.m
and i therefore declare this meeting
closed with my thanks to everybody
involved
thank you
you